so I want women to understand that these
are not things that we can take for
granted and I want them to understand
how our daily issues our kitchen table
topping so far sleeping related to
government hi Matt Welch for recent TV
I'm here in Las Vegas at freedom fest
with Michelle Lieberman speaking of
freedom fest she's the founder of
freedom friend that's right the freedom
friend which you're going to explain in
a second but first let's actress/model
living in hollywood a self-described
former liberal what happened in your
brain that turns you into some kind of
libertarian so I actually have been
massively into pop culture my entire
life and the thing that triggered it was
the 2008 elections when I was watching
Bronn Paul question about electability
do you have any sir there is always the
question as to whether or not but you
are in fact as I was watching these
elections I was watching the debates I
was watching them not invite him to a
debate I was watching them not allow him
to answer certain questions I was kind
of curious like he was this guy like why
won't they let him talk and so it was
the first time i went to a politician's
website never ever had any reason to
ever go to a politician's website so i
went to his website and was reading what
he was saying and it kind of made sense
and
then I actually started listening to
what they were talking about which is
something I've never done and I I'm an
educated person and I have never fully
understood all of the terminology being
used like in the news or in campaigns
and so I started to pay attention and he
was delivering a message that i was
completely on board for and I started to
realize that my liberal ideas were not
in line with what Ron Paul was saying
and i read with everything in a saying
what were some of those ideas that
struck you as this makes sense here and
it's not what I come from like what
attracted you well he was talking he was
talking about limited government and
free-market capitalism and how I
remember him making a comment about how
businesses grow when they're left alone
without so much regulation and he just
he said something that kind of made
sense and I was just starting my own
business I have a personal styling
business and as a business owner I
started to look at things in a different
way versus like when I was just an
employee or when I was just being hired
by a studio or a production company and
you just don't think about it and went
as a business owner I started to pay
attention to texts
these regulations and the things the red
tape that I have to go through and he
started saying things that were
relatable to me whereas they were never
relatable to me before and he was
talking at the Fed the Federal Reserve
and he was the first time that I ever
found out that they were a private thing
of course I thought they were government
entity and I started doing some reading
on central banks and what he was saying
about the Fed so that was a huge one for
me I was really interested in I'm a
finance major was really interested in
what he was saying about money so now
you're starting up freedom friend you're
trying to reach out to people like you
you're kind of friends right who aren't
necessarily into politics tell us what
you're doing while you're doing and how
are you doing it so the freedom friend
is supposed to be I want this to be
something that's palatable to most
Americans to mainstream America and a
lot of politics tends to go over the
heads and most people I'm an educated
woman a lot of stuff was going over my
head and unfortunately too we have a
culture nowadays it's very very pop
culture and views our attention spans
are five to ten seconds you don't have
someone's attention in that quick of a
time like you've lost them and so I want
to merge the pop-culture message with
politics because every single thing
that we do in our daily lives every
little thing that we don't think about
is affected by our government systems
and I think most women especially don't
realize this and I think they disempower
themselves when they don't when they
don't want to vote or don't want to pay
attention to what's going on with
Congress they don't pay attention to who
their representatives are and that's
huge those are huge factors to having a
government system that allows us to have
the American Way and that's what we're
used to in the American Way is I'm now
seeing that it's deteriorating and I
have to immigrant parents like I'm first
generation American here and I heard
stories about all of these socialist
countries that they came from and it's
not hard for governments to completely
take over and and for you to lose your
freedom that easily like I just my
parents are from countries with zero
freedom and I'm starting to see that
here and so I want women to understand
that these are not things that we can
take for granted and I want them to
understand how our daily issues our
kitchen table topics far completely
related to government that's great thank
you very much for joining us for recent
TV I'm